on pense aux cuisses de l'été et on va
bien sûr ma singer troisième saison d
audience guillaume qui ont été corrects
au tfc au dessus des 3 millions de
téléspectateurs mais c'est une émission
qui coûte extrêmement cher on avait d'un
million d'euros par prague ah oui quand
même on a un petit récap on en parle
juste après
cette saison on a regardé masking heures
sur tf1 l'émission la plus celle du paf
avec des stars internacional ait
fini franchement c'était une saison qui
vendait du rêve aura pas une mais
plusieurs stars internationales sauf que
le jury ça fait trois saisons qu'il est
là du coup il sait que les grosses stars
c'est pas trop le genre de la maison
c'est maintenant le moment de nous
donner un nom moi j'étais sûr text surya
bonaly et vincent lagaf philippe
manoeuvre valletta des mouches anwar
tout ben ali on a aussi vu plein de
beaux costumes et c'est sur internet on
peut trouver des costumes de serre tout
rigolo celui qu'on a vu sur le plateau
était un peu plus flippant merci de
faire du bruit pour le sait
et on a aussi vu notre costume préféré
avec cet arbre qui avait l'air
complètement stone
mais
deux minutes plus tard qu'eva dams a
tenté de faire une petite blagounette
tient un point commun avec l'arbre nous
avons tous les deux des champignons
sinon après avoir provoqué tout le monde
dans les premières émissions se faisant
passer pour chantal ladesou chantal tu
as été exceptionnel
on s'est rendu compte que cette émission
c'était vraiment du foutage de gueule
comme marc-antoine le bret est revenu
une deuxième fois cette fois ci ça paie
dans un costume croco sortie nulle part
soit alors certes de code et à en croire
la tête du jury en avait peut-être un
peu marre de toutes les semaines
ça fait beaucoup là non
voilà pour la gêner alors bon cette
émission elle a très bien démarré à plus
de 6 millions $ et à terre la première
saison de 23 millions en deux ans c'est
quand même pas mal et sur les cibles
d'été à 48 ils sont tombés à 38 donc
c'est globalement positif reste que ça
reste très cher ça reste très cher puis
le concept pardon mais c'est rien certes
deviner son sketch où un arbre travaux
devraient commencer votre note c3 oui ma
note ces trois parce que le concept sait
rien en fait c'est là où il ya une
grande injustice entre les chaînes comme
tf1 et les autres chaînes tf1 peut se
permettre ça parce qu'ils ont plein
d'argent et avec plein d'argent on peut
faire de rien une émission regardable
parce qu'il ya des décors très cher des
costumes qui sont extrêmement chères un
jury mine de rien plutôt pas mal qui ait
payé aussi extrêmement cher jusqu'à 300
mille euros par part personnalité donc
voila et une campagne de communication
énorme c'est encore l'une des rares
émissions vous avez des affiches dans la
rue où ça ya des centaines de milliers
d'euros qui sont dépensés si vous mettez
ça sur la tnt ça fait deux cent mille
téléspectateurs pour moi cette émission
c'est l'apologie du rien
mais c'est vrai qu'ils ont vendu du rêve
et que vos ballons alors il y avait et
d'habiter sympa chez la llo david
douillet le kop daigné de lévis liane
foly dave damidot laure manaudou bon
c'est des gens qu'on connaît mais c'est
pas non plus exceptionnel oui mais a
progressé nettement supérieur vous
mettez moi j'ai mis 5 parce que j'ai
regardé quand même un peu d'abord
j'aurais bien voulu intégrer le jury à
300000 euros
mais non la promesse était tellement
supérieur oui si tu es jurés tu gagnes
300 mille balles pour ses commerces tant
mieux pour eux
ils sont sympathiques mais non c'est la
promesse en te dis en plus si entre ma
me disais c'est peut-être madonna c'est
peut-être shakira sait peut-être
n'importe quoi parce que quand ils vous
voient en la promesse de dire c'est une
star internationale exactement une ils
ont eu la casse elle est pas belle la
vie' vidéo un chanteur américain s'il ya
eu 6
de desperate un match héroïque qui avait
disparu malgré un joueur a été quand
même
la série
non non c'est pas ça à la promesse est
tellement supérieur qu'on est déçu
forcément mais autrement bon pas bon
jouer sur pas mal entamée aux yeux moi
j'ai mis sept je trouve que c'est sympa
surtout que ça mais un tout le on en
parle même entre nous qui tu penses qu'à
qui sous son costume etc non non mais
franchement
dans l'émission c'est sympa plus des
costumes sur marche moins bien fait ça
on peut pas dire le contraire serait
cédé beaucoup surtout le zélé moi j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt sympa bonjour chez nous
devrions savoir qu'ils se caser le la
revoilà
devrait plus télévision moi j'ai bien
aimé ouais mais c'est vrai je trouve ça
pas mal regardé quand il me semble que
non
mais c'est
de bon augure et la la la la la la
kermesse de fin d'année de l'école de
mon fils tu vas lille et les boutons
consumer les costumes sont pas bons
annoncée mauvaise foi arrêtent on dirait
gilles verdez était pas t'es pas bien là
j'aime pas quand tu es sans doute
aussi oui moi j'aime bien alors pas
forcément à regarder mais je nous allons
alors journal et j'aime bien les
missions qu'on va pas regarder donc
c'est carrément un concept
téléspectatrice en revanche vu que j'ai
beaucoup d'empathie je me dis que les
gens qui participent doit vraiment
apprécié l'expérience de pouvoir chanter
sans être jugé parce que on ne nous voit
pas on est dans une carapace donc moi
pour le côté humain de l'expérience tout
le monde rêve de donner la mort vive
d'expérience d'être enfermé dans la codi
de ridiculiser
crie sa voix donc c'est horrible ils
perdent énormément de poids j'ai lu
tellement les costumes sont très très
loose et
j'ai envie de dire que c'est une
muséographe la tête non ça grésille
la bouche ça peut prétendre enseigner la
chine cette salade de mangue donc pour
d'une ag vous m 5 non j'ai mis 5 parce
que je sais pas pourquoi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
explications j'adore avant de voir les
extraits j'ai mis
en regardant les extrêmes qui sont là je
mets 0 c'est vrai c'est une catastrophe
alors là vous avez qui a gagné la saison
une non mais pas du tout orange
boccolini
la santé vient d'ailleurs oui la saison
2 la rousse au laos où des dizaines
étaient déguisés en branche eau
et en saison 3 non je dénie ça ils
kononova ah oui ah oui je sais comment
gérer ses dires le nom sont le
sens le chier
mais on ne peut pas faire ma singer par
passion qu'on fasse danse avec les stars
ce qu'on aime bien la danse qu'on fasse
le meilleur feeling est ok mais quel
plaisir ignace caché dans un pingouin
enfin pardon
ça pour cachetonner et en plus ça n'a
aucun intérêt pour les célébrités en
termes de médiatisation puisque par
définition on les voit pas à l'antenne
on les voit deux secondes donc s'étonner
s'agissait uniquement pour cachetonner
elle durera après alors il faut pour
respecter le choix des artistes qui dès
qu'ils ont fait mais il est vrai des
ventes à gagner de l'argent
ils sont payants fait voter son pays et
bien sûr ils sont là pour l'oseille
c'est tout
alors danse avec les
jeux parce qu'elle entre danse et que
les stars où il travaille cinq saisons
par jour et une semaine pour faire
nommer rosine scorer et la faire un
playback ils ont enregistré 3 mois al
avance en bidouillant la voie avec des
effets s'est passé sa journée dans un
crocodile
iman une banane non mais les spectacles
qu'ils offraient été pas mal c'était
joli entonné comme si bernard les
chorégraphies très belle merci bernard
n'a qu il se décrit comme vous mettez
comme go comme notre vous moi j'ai mis
sept mois moi je dois ça me fait penser
à alice au pays des merveilles a vu la
belle et la bête moi j'aime bien
ce que je voulais peut-être dire c'est
que aux etats unis ils en sont à la
septième saison il sait ils ont eu comme
candidat rudy giuliani savez unique
semaine
de new york donc c'est une vraie
personnalité se serait peut-être bien
que ici on aurait par exemple à kano
et ça pourrait peut-être un peu rageant
dire la chose et en angleterre ils vont
commencer la jolie quatrième saison ils
ont eu comme candidate nathalie
imbruglia
donc sénégal où ça me ferait sans doute
mais alors ça dans la vie on a été
approché la belle ex belle fille
d'elizabeth ii donc voyez qu'il ratisse
large les fiancés que en amérique j'ai
l'impression qu'on voit et ce qu'il faut
comme spectacle les stars se prêtent à
plein de chauny se prête avec plaisir
donc c'est pas choquant de retrouver une
vraie star dans la re coded en amérique
mal alors que chez nous c'est pas le
mien
il ya peu de chances que gims il se
cache dans un hard to peer et bien alors
on ira pas tu as vu les poules c malgré
ses rêves non ici des personnes dont on
n'a pas autre fonction bad bank d'actu
et dont on n'a pas entendu par la
générale c'est vrai qu'on veut faire
monter un petit magnéto pour qu'on voit
des gens on n'avait pas vu depuis
longtemps
attention c'est on va savoir maintenant
c'est bien le chef yves camdeborde 7e
qui suivait la bonne piste avec jacuzzi
10 costumes étaient les cinq anneaux sur
la coquille en référence aux anneaux
olympiques
et le costume bernard l'hermite était un
rappel évident au nom de famille d'alain
bernard au tout départ ah qu'est ce
qu'on avait pensé unique ouakam jean
pierre raffarin
le corps et qu'elle attaque et
n'ouvre pas moi j'allais me alain
bernard a voilà donc il ya des gens
effectivement extrêmement connue alors
que ça fait pas mal même plutôt très
bien on avait de l'or ournac n'ont pas
dit
c'est bien que j'aie sentez vous
rafraîchir la mémoire regardez l'extrait
[Musique]
sauvez moi ça c'est exigeant
nous sommes sereins
m
chante magnifiquement bien
[Musique]
je vais demander ce qu'ils en ont pensé
nos enquêteurs et puis on a la chance
d'avoir un deuxième chanteur
professionnel ce soir c'est qu'elle j en
part sur un duo avec le crd que c'est la
fin de l'aventuré c'est incroyable tu
chantes tu es très bien monsieur le
cercle franchement tu m'a bluffé pas
comme moi tout le monde je m'appelle hd
produit est
alors vous avez vu il ya kenjy dans le
en guest québec et le jury vous rappelez
de la boulette de tf1 que kenji était
dans un costume ah oui et en fait comme
il intègre et après le jury il quand ils
en ont fait la bande annonce on voyait
qu'ils hésitent donc à coup les gens
étaient totalement perdus perdu et du
coup du d'avant ils ont démasqué eux
mêmes la stack il fallait tout regarder
ses amis
la semaine prochaine c'est la
demi-finale de masse
pour l'événement un nouveau personnage
fera son apparition kiev enquêteurs va
vous accompagner durant toute l'émission
et vous allez devoir deviner qui sait
et cette célébrité sera là pour aider à
faire avancer l'enquêté soit une
sportive sur notre dette
et pour la première fois dans masque
singer nos cinq enquêteurs pourront
s'approcher de chaque personnage
singer nos sites
[Musique]
oui oui l après
midi
la gaffe à propos de bassinger non parce
qu'en fait savoir que le producteur de
ma singers et l'ancien producteur de la
gare servait d'intermédiaire en fait il
n'a été appelé approché pour lui pensé
pour animer pour armer et en fait il
mieux est d'être dans un costume je
pense que le producteur s'est fait bien
recevoir oui je suis vraiment ça a été
un petit peu compliqué ceci dit moi
quand j'étais sûr sur tf1 profite d'une
émission toof annoncé l'ap hp
c'était l'audience est pareil j'étais un
peu en fin de l'entrain de partir de
deux de tf1 n'était pas très heureux et
j'ai un coup de téléphone des actions
qui dit jamais ce que tu veux faire
plouf eu ce match mais et j'ai dit je
dis ouais bah pour l'animer je passe
devant l'affiché annonce était pas pour
si c'était pour mettre en maillot de
bain et s'est posé il n'est pas trop
fort parce que jp lâcher quand même
fournir j'ai pas eu le choix c'est ce
qui m'a conté m'a coûté mon départ de
tf1 samassa
ap avec des anciens de la direction
pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi parce qu'on
m'a dit il serait préférable que tu
fasses ce jeu est derrière ça suivra et
alors que j'ai dit ok on annoncé un prix
on m'a rappelé en demie à falloir que tu
fais bien ton cacher et il serait
préférable que tu le fasses j'ai dit ok
et après le jour n'a jamais rappelé mais
c'était c'est pas de tf1 c'est les
attaques étaient en voie là où c'est
écrit des non non je peux pas se fait
pas je passe à la télé mais j'espère que
ça c'est la version neo - parce qu'il
avait répondu c'est à dire dans la dent
dans la série section de recherches
vendredi la série s'arrêter justement à
lyon m'a dit derrière vale bailleur
d'autres choses voilà mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a des toutes petites
couilles excusez moi du terme mais je le
recroise très tôt ou tard il se
reconnaît et qu'on fait trop vous à on
vous a conseillé de faire cette émission
pas terrible on on m'a dit c'est normal
on manage d'euros m'a dit il serait
préférable que et derrière ça va suivre
en gros sa part des gens au suicide
parce que je savais que c'était pas moi
j'y croyais pas quoi puis m'ont dit oui
mais tu sais plan que j'ai été un
sauveteur super en sauveteur histoire
d'hommes plongeant les planches pitot
et donc j'ai fait ça va à contre coeur
en plus et et puis dès que j'ai fini les
missions plus de nouvelles
voilà voilà voilà et la télé ont pour
finir avec ma singer donc cette émission
a été re signer pour une quatrième
saison oui c'est toujours un million
d'euros à l'unité environ ce qui est
extrêmement cher mais quand vous
regardez les primes de m6 parents
d'aujourd'hui sont à 300000 euros 400000
euros parfois deux cent mille euros et
ça fait 2 3 millions mario premier
regarde ça cartonne et ça coûte cinq
fois moins cher comment est-ce que le
décor est ce que la chaîne justifie un
tel prix parce que après les costumes
sont très beaux et costumes c'est des
dizaines de milliers d'euros et jury les
jurys qui prennent trois cent mille
euros alors les autres c - hénin qui
prend beaucoup beaucoup d'argent les
décors sont comme moi lassé des beaux
décors des beaux plateaux il ya une
logistique est incroyable c'est tout une
confidentialité est respectée donc c'est
une émission qui coûte très cher à
produire pour masquer le manque de
concepts parfait tout simplement à votre
avis à quel niveau tf1 perd de l'argent
de l'audience en dessous 3 millions je
pense donc celle donc donc ça arrive on
re c'est vrai là ils sont encore à 3
millions donc ça va ça reste des bons
scores 1 tf1 ne fait plus 3 millions
après mais il faut enfin les 3 million
seller bonjour à l'époque où vous étiez
c'était quoi 5,6 millions et à 3
millions cdn kadirov mois alors à
l'époque de ou de bernard qui était à
bien avant boite f1 faut savoir qu'il ya
cinq ans maintenant la grande époque de
tf1 si on faisait pas 40% de parts de
marché
c'était pas bien il fallait au moins 30
ans
ménagères de moins de cinquante ans
c'était 30 et 40 en dessous de ça dont
faisait pas un coup de fil et c'était la
figure imposée mais à l'époque qui
montait à 50 60 à gerland large éléments
je vous ai plus il y avait pas autant de
chaînes non plus avec moi il n'y avait
pas la tnt encore mais et c'est vrai
qu'on fait des scores la moitié des
français regardez nos émissions en
moyenne oui c'est énorme maintenant
c'est la moitié de ma famille
la moyenne pour bassinger sais combien
c'est passé c'est pas si mal quand même
temps c'est une chouette démission je
pense à 5 4 pour les actions passées et
pour une émission qu'on a largement
défoncé c'est pas mal quand même